[ YouTube Learning ]
Now you are well aware of
how you can communicate with your students
through Google Classroom.
But how can you share or create materials for them?
Let’s explore!
[ Don't Memorise intro music ]
Study materials could be information,
or assignments or videos
or even your pre-existing teaching aids
you may have created earlier!
For that we can access the Classwork tab
you see here.
You could first create a TOPIC
that you want your students to understand,
and add different kinds of materials to it.
You can click here,
and give a name to the topic.
With that, you will see the name of your topic
listed on the left here.
Now let’s add some material to this topic.
It’s crucial to give your material
some appropriate title and description...
Once you do that,
you have an option to ADD some material
that you have already prepared,
or the option to create one.
Let’s try creating
or importing a Google Doc in this video,
and in the upcoming videos,
we can look at the other options!
We can click on Create, and select Docs.
And that will open a new Document.
We can give it a name
by editing this part here.
Now most people assume that Google Docs
is just about letters and words,
but trust me,
there’s lots more to it.
Let me give you a few examples.
You could click on Tools,
select voice typing,
select your language and see magic.
We begin the recording now.
“An equation says that two things are equal.
Full stop.”
And now we stop the recording.
Interesting isn’t it?
You can also insert an image from your computer.
Or you could also search
for an image on the web,
select it, and add it to the document.
You can also include equations and special characters.
You could also redirect your students
to an external website by inserting
a link in the Doc… like this…
But make sure you have vetted the website
prior to sharing it.
And guess what,
you don’t need to keep saving it.
It keeps getting auto-saved
every time you add information.
There are many more features,
but we’ll keep that for later.
We can now close the doc, by closing the tab.
You will see your Google Doc here now.
If you don’t see it updated,
just refresh the page.
You can then assign it to your topic
by clicking here and selecting the topic.
And you can choose if you want to share it
with all your students,
or just a select few.
After you have added enough information,
you can either post it immediately,
or schedule it for a later date,
or simply just save your information.
Let’s post it for now.
You can now see that the material
will appear in your Stream Section.
And your students as well
will be able to see it in the Stream section!
The good thing is that unless, you allow them,
the students will not be able to EDIT your Docs
They can just view them.
That’s how easy it is to share
a Google Doc file with your students.
You can use Google Docs on any
smartphone, laptop or tablet.
You can even edit it while you are offline
and it will sync changes once you go online.
So Google Docs is one way in which
you can share material with your students.
Watch the next video to know
how you could share beautiful presentations
with your students!
See you there!
[ #TeachFromAnywhere ]
[ YouTube Learning ]